Kobra...
Kobra.
Le combat...
est inévitable.
S'il vous plaît, pourriez-vous m'aider
à transporter mes sacs?
C'est laquelle, votre voiture?
C'est la grise là-bas.
Merci, jeune homme.
Vous avez l'air nouveau.
Oh, ça va bien se passer.
Moi, ça fait 50 ans que je suis là.
Neuf petits-enfants, je peux vous dire
que ça maintient en forme.
Oh, et bienvenue au Zoo!
"Je crois que t'as capté le message
(Allô?)
Le rap est anthropophage
Du sang sur le linge,
il faut que je passe à la laverie
Dieu m'a fait à son image,
et puis j'ai tourné la page
On est tous des singes
Je ne fais que des singeries
(Chakal)"
Finis bien sur les TN,
finis bien sur les TN.
Alors, lourd ou pas?
Je ne sais pas.
Je t'ai dit, ce n'est peut-être pas
le morceau à clipper,
tu en as des meilleurs.
Ah ouais?
Du genre?
Oh putain, il y a Rhino, wesh.
Casse les couilles, celui-là.
Oh, ça dit quoi, les artistes?
Téma le beau gosse, il a claqué
tout son RSA, il est content.
Je ne sais pas comment tu fais
pour trouver ta taille,
gros chacal, va!
C'est quoi, des prototypes sur-mesure?
Tu en achètes deux, tu les colles ensemble?
C'est pour ça que tu n'as jamais
de biff, hein?
Oh, tu n'entends pas
quand je te parle ou quoi?
Ouais, ouais, ouais,
ouais, ouais.
Ouais, en fait, je rachète des sapes
des gros rappeurs,
tu vois, genre bien se-gro de ouf.
DJ Khaled et tout, Rick Ross, tout ça.
Et dès qu'ils percent, ils se mettent à la muscu,
et du coup, je récupère tout, en fait.
Attends, attends, tu te fous de ma gueule, c'est ça?
Wesh Yéni, tu es sérieux?
Je vais à la boutique, normal.
Et d'où tu fais des clips
sans demander la permission?
Tu te crois où, là?
Depuis quand, il y a des serpents ici, hein?
C'est qui, lui?
Oh, le ver de terre!
On ne t'a pas appris à dire bonjour
avant de passer?
Hey, tu viens d'où, toi?
Aaaaaah!
Fils de pute!
Continue de crier, tu ne vas rien
faire du tout, il y a R!
Vous vouliez me voir?
Approche-toi.
Dis-moi,
à quoi reconnaît-on les êtres
les plus méritants?
Maître, je peux vous expliquer.
On les reconnaît
parce qu'ils sont les derniers en vie.
Et nous méritons de vivre.
Goldi…
Excuse-moi, je n'ai pas entendu.
J'ai mérité ma liberté.
Je ne veux plus combattre.
Rappelle-toi le précepte que tu enseignais:
"Quand tous les os de ton corps
seront brisés, tu pourras te reposer."
Non!
Aaaaaaah!
Je veux partir.
Tu as raison.
Tu en as assez fait.
Je lui ai offert la mort qu'il souhaitait.
Mais ne pleurons pas ceux
qui nous ont permis de survivre,
honorons les survivants.
La liberté qu'il chérissait tant,
Goldi, est à notre portée.
Kobra, elle n'était pas à la sienne.
Salut, voisin, ça dit quoi?
Tu as un nom ou je t'appelle "Serpent"?
Moi, c'est Chakal.
Elle, c'est Jaco.
Tu sais, on est en face de ta porte.
Tu vois, je crèche chez elle.
J'ai une petite galère…
Enfin bref, vas-y, t'as capté.
C'est un ouf, lui, à pas me répondre.
Vas-y, réponds-moi avant
que je ne te monte en l'air!
Tu es sûr là, frérot?
Lourd, ce que tu as fait en bas,
le petit coup en scred.
Je connais, je connais,
je connais.
Oh, chef !
Bah ouais, Serpent, je taquine !
J'aurais pu passer pro en boxe.
Après, je me suis fait les croisés.
Tu connais, les problèmes.
Maintenant, je kick un peu.
Là, je vais bientôt sortir ma mixtape.
Je vais tout dead, frérot.
Ils ne sont pas prêts.
Attends, attends…
Calme-toi.
Il est juste venu te demander
si tu ne voulais pas bosser avec lui,
enfin avec nous.
Avec sa grande gueule.
Quand il va cé-per, il risque d'avoir
des galères s'il n'a pas un mec comme toi.
Genre, tu sais, garde du corps,
un truc comme ça, tu as vu?
Ça paierait mieux que vigile.
Tu sais, tout le monde a envie
d'avoir les moyens de partir d'ici.
Je ne cherche pas d'amis,
je ne cherche pas à partir d'ici non plus.
Ah OK, c'est toi qui vois.
De toute façon, tu sais où on est
si tu changes d'avis.
Hum, Kobra, te voilà bien entouré.
Monsieur Kobra ?
C'est vous?
Où est-il?
Sortez de chez moi!